50 millions d'unités créés chaque année
h2 pharma est le premier producteur
français de spécialités pharmaceutiques
non stériles henry hassid dans son
entreprise en 1984 il est tout juste
diplômé et s'installe à cachan dans le
val de marne
notre spécialité c'est de développer de
produire tout ce qui va être liquidée
dans un flacon autrement dit tout ce qui
est siro et tout ce qui est bonne bouche
donc aujourd'hui nous sommes leader en
france et nous continuons à développer
des nouveaux produits pour sortir élargi
un petit peu notre panoplie produit h2
pharma emploie une quarantaine de
salariés la société souhaite s'agrandir
en lançant deux projets nous avons
décidé et cette extension et le
développement de ce laboratoire et de
cette structure high tech pour le
service aux laboratoires pharmaceutiques
et une opportunité a fait que nous avons
récupéré un autre bâtiment que nous
allons revampé entièrement pour faire
une nouvelle unité de production h2
pharma a sollicité la région pour
bénéficier du fonds de relance elle se
voit doté d'une aide de 800 mille euros
la plus importante de ce fonds on a
perdu beaucoup d'emplois industriels ces
dernières années et enfin sur 25 ans et
est donc du coup avec des conséquences
économiques et sociales très importante
donc nous on veut faire notamment
revenir de l'industrie en ile de france
on parle beaucoup de souveraineté
industrielle en ce moment notamment dans
le domaine des médicaments et aider
cette industrie à se moderniser à se
transformer pour créer de l'emploi et
être leader sur tout un tas de marché
une aide qui pourrait créer 30 emplois
avec des investissements prévus sur les
deux prochaines années sa capacité
globale de production sera de 140
millions d'unités